this is for you but we will win not just
one championship not to LeBron I'm sorry
you might want to read this this wait
not it's concerned some changes next
year if this is about Delhi going to the
box I think we'll live and we should be
happy with this one there's a new king
to the east this again didn't we do this
last year we've got the chemistry and
the defense to take you down don't sleep
on a to see my dear King for the north
will soon rule reached we are the new
kings under eat this again didn't we do
this last year 60 wins countin it puts
us into one seed and our house goes 12
men deep we are the Spurs of the East
Tellem core for bird this year there
will be a new king of the east we're
doing this again
you're on your last leg LeBron there
will be a new king in the east and this
time I mean it
here Paul you literally did this last
year the era of poor George raw Heba and
how spaces begins now
verticality there will be a new king in
the East we're doing this they say your
super team can't be big but wake up the
original big fray and I say anything is
possible
yes yes cheer brave men all of you took
six games to be the house that I three
less wins this year than the Nuggets
haven't you little northern nice killing
pawns means nothing if you can't fell
the king am i dying
no we're just choking you get used to it
when people ask you what happened here
tell them King James still rules the
east also tell them I'm better than
Michael Jordan okay well is there
anything I could possibly do to win you
over
yes okay you got winner six
championships what you realize Colby
only 1/5
yeah but he's a closer [ __ ] finishes
ice I finish according to the analytics
maesters I'm actually more clutch than
Kobe nah Kobe's a killer like a mum bass
well I built a school Wow oh you built a
school yeah that's cuz you're soft yeah
you'd have to give up your entire young
cool for my rights I would trade every
single one of them for just a chance to
play with you between you and me they're
a bunch of fools and overhyped Squires
even the ball boy for long though good
riddance demanders Oh from a father and
once he's gone we'll bring in a real
Lord Commander
like Jason quit stock just son of a--
are you completely mad
he saw us don't trade me i'm really good
except for shooting free throws and
three-pointers layups but the numbers
you pick he was the number two pick the
things I do for rings house Lakers hi
okay so we are good
everyone knows how this works not really
empty not to regards our house is on the
rise
Zion joins I may be a 42 year old Vince
Carter won't have to play 17 minutes of
battle okay who else in SOTA I mean how
many number one picks do you guys need
to make the tournament apparently more
than three this is fun
hey do us know who else house Wizards I
mean who wouldn't want to play with
Dwight Howard
by the way when does John Wolfe super
start next year asking for friend okay
who else we got how schools oh yeah I'm
sure Zion wants to spend his first year
having Naomi okay all right LeBron okay
show a little respect for many of these
houses this is the highlight of their
season oh yeah why is that maybe instead
of looking to the gods you all should be
looking at yourselves
rubbish houses with uninspiring Lord
commanders foolish masters of trade
arrogant lords no bad these are things
at night no matter how great can't
overcome and learned that the hard way
Zion may be the prince who was promised
but he will not save you because if you
don't give a goat the support he needs
the knees gonna walk out the door and
all you're gonna be left with poop on
the floor thank you hey guys guys hey
guys hey everyone so glad you all could
be here I just figured since so many of
you summer in Los Angeles anyway it
would be fun to invite everyone over to
my new brentwood castle for some
mingling some pampering a little
tampering but before we dig into our
delicious fast fired or tis no place
meat thighs I do have some big news Ben
Simmons ate a three-pointer I did oh
speaking of which my servant I mean my
lord commanders have informed me that
the pies are ready so everybody say it
with me it's time for me five
[Music]
hey how's grumpy boys so you're on
Brooklyn now eh
indeed we are oh I love it such a good
fit great young call for you to
demoralize Oh Alex Caruso's here excuse
me gentlemen Oh you guys leaving no
we're just about to start a big 1k
tournament oh I'd love to but I actually
played a game yesterday and you know I'm
trying to manage me load understood well
so glad you guys could come and so
excited for this little crosstown
rivalry remember guys the only beef here
is in the pies all right what's going on
with Dion over there okay yeah I think
he might be in my special pie
oh damn it junior
[Music]
you